[Música]
quiero venir a hablarles en poco que lo
que pienso yo que es el rol del
emprendimiento de un emprendedor en el
mundo a partir de mi experiencia y lo
que he vivido cuando el ser humano llega
al mundo llega con una curiosidad
y nata
por explorar o tratar de entender su
mundo y con ganas de aprender
también por tratar de descifrar el
futuro por la curiosidad porque es el
futuro que nos depara el futuro
los emprendedores creo que tienen todas
estas características exaltadas cuando
yo era niño
y le preguntaban a uno que quiere ser
cuando grande yo decía yo quiero ser
inventor era una persona muy curiosa
con muchas ganas de aprender me gustaba
mucho también los riesgos ser apasionado
por los riesgos hasta el punto que una
vez me tiré de una ventana en un segundo
piso una sombrilla para ver si volaba
como mary poppins
crecía con una tremenda admiración por
mis padres que también son emprendedores
con todo s con todo ese ejemplo y con
todo ese entorno que viví cuando era
pequeño empecé a explorar cosas como por
ejemplo desbaratar la licuadora de la
casa desbaratar el computador tratar de
aprender y tratar de entender cómo
funcionaban era parte de mi esencia
tratar de de saber cómo funcionaban las
cosas me fue también con eso que
arreglaba las cosas que se bañaban en la
casa y las mamás de mis amigos me
mandaban la licuadora la plancha
etcétera para que se las arreglará
algunas veces le sobraban piezas pero la
mayoría de las veces las dejaba
funcionando
luego durante el colegio empecé a
a probar nuevas cosas a experimentar
nuevas cosas ya tratar de aplicarlas
aprendí a programar cuando tenía 10 años
con un computador que
tenía 16 kilobytes que es menos de lo
que tienen las calculadoras de hoy en
día
y ya cuando estaba más grande en los
últimos en los últimos años del colegio
empecé a desarrollar software o a probar
agua oa probar nuevas cosas empecé a
tener como ciertas ideas que empecé a
desarrollar como por ejemplo troncos
ecológicos para chimenea
software para la biblioteca del colegio
software de facturación para un papá de
un amigo y todo esto lo hice en los
últimos años del colegio
después de mucho esfuerzo creando
aprendiendo fracasando aprendiendo esos
fracasos sin hace cinco años
fundamos stars y con mi socio taxi llegó
a hacer
la aplicación de taxis más popular en
colombia pero ser emprendedor tiene sus
contras
requiere sacrificios
muchas veces fracasos fracasé muchas
veces pero lo más importante es
el aprendizaje que uno logra de sus
fracasos poderse levantar y levantarse y
seguir adelante
pero también tiene sus pros y sus pros
y lo es pero son
algo como poder trabajar en lo que no le
gusta en lo que uno le apasiona poderse
concentrar en eso poder crear cosas
nuevas la independencia y un aprendizaje
constante algo que definitivamente
me apasiona poder estar aprendiendo de
cualquier cosa de cualquier persona en
todo momento
y lo más importante también es que uno
puede
e intentar lograr hacer el mundo un
poquito mejor y crear el futuro en taxi
por ejemplo
estamos mejorando la vida a dos millones
de personas mensualmente cuando quieren
transportarse de manera segura de manera
fácil y conveniente
y estamos mejorando en la vida a 50.000
conductores que ahora tienen una mejor
calidad de vida
tiene mayores ingresos tiene más tiempo
para sus familias y trabajan de una
manera más segura en la calle ahora
estamos apostándole a un nuevo
emprendimiento un emprendimiento con un
reto aún más grande en el que queremos
impactar la vida de 30 millones de
colombianos inicialmente 400 millones de
latinoamericanos que no están
bancarizados personas que han sido
ignoradas por él por el sistema
financiero por los bancos
es una billetera móvil que le va a
permitir a las personas poder hacer
pagos seguros sin efectivo y con te paga
tuve la oportunidad del año pasado de
participar en guays combinator que es la
aceleradora tecnología más grande del
mundo en silicon valley sube cuatro
meses en
en san francisco
y tuve la oportunidad de trabajar con
otros emprendedores del mundo porque es
una aceleradora que trae gente de todo
el mundo
uno se impresiona con los proyectos tan
ambiciosos que está trabajando esta
gente tuve la oportunidad de trabajar a
lado a lado con gente que está
construyendo diseñando propulsores para
cohetes con personas que están creando
produciendo proteína a partir de
insectos usando nuevas tecnologías
también para detección temprana de
alzhéimer unos proyectos muy
interesantes muy ambiciosos que uno ve
que tienen un futuro impresionante para
cambiar el mundo
entonces hay gente en todo el mundo
generando nuevas ideas trabajando por
sus sueños y metiéndole pasión a esas
ideas para intentar cambiar el mundo el
mundo necesita más emprendedores más
gente dispuesta a apostarle por sacar
adelante esas ideas
podemos desarrollar en nuestros hijos
las habilidades que se requieren para
ser emprendedor
desde incentivarles la curiosidad que
compartan y experimenten y hagan cosas
con sus compañeros que trabajen en
equipo que se comuniquen bien
dejarles explorar su creatividad y
dejarles que se equivoquen y que
aprendan de esos errores nuestros hijos
pueden impactar el mundo
ustedes jóvenes también van a poder
impactar el mundo como lo van a hacer
gracias